tonight Democrats on the defense as
their own Russian scandal widens an FBI
informant working undercover at the time
of the controversial uranium 1 deal is
now free to talk the Justice Department
has lifted a big a gag order so he can
tell his story to lawmakers who want to
know more about the Obama
administration's
uranium deals with Moscow and about the
cash that flowed to the Clinton
Foundation amid the deals the White
House says Democrats have a big problem
on their hands
I think this further proves if there was
anyone that was colluding with the
Russians to influence the election look
no further than the Clintons look no
further than the DNC this is hypocrisy
at its highest level and I think it may
be a new low in American politics
everything that the Clinton campaign and
the DNC were falsely accusing this
president of doing over the past year
they were actually doing themselves it
turns out and I think that this is a
major scandal for the Democrats the
ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee sees the uranium
one probe as part of an effort to take
attention away from the special counsels
investigation into the Trump teams
possible coordination with the Russians
this had to be orchestrated with the
approval of the Speaker of the House and
so this is a partisan effort to distract
it's a partisan effort aligned with what
the White House has been urging and Fox
and Breitbart and which there was no
consultation with the Democrats in
Congress and I think that tells you all
you need to know about whether this is
in good faith or not Dayna big news
today and a lot of people back and forth
on this including the White House taking
a position coming out and attacking you
saw with Sarah Sanders there yeah so
it's a different way to deal with it so
usually with a special investigation and
you just like basically you say well
we'll let the Justice Department handle
it but we're in a different sort of
world right now and I think anything
that the White House can do to suggest
that there was a problem on a democratic
side if it comes to Russia that probably
benefits them politically because it
just makes everything super confusing
and looks like everybody's bad I mean I
cannot believe how many people in
Washington were
dealing with Russia but I also think
that this deal this Sofia [ __ ] fists
whatever we want to call it the
committee for a foreign investment the
United States it is nine different
departments all looking at something so
it wasn't as if Hillary Clinton just
signed it
don't just did it herself I am curious
about this informant this is unusual for
a gag order like this to be lifted and
apparently this came directly from the
president and the speaker putting
pressure on the FBI who complied and so
we don't know this person's identity yet
I understand it's a male so we'll call
my man but we'll hopefully find out that
out soon and then I don't know if he'll
have any additional information or if
they'll just be more part of an ongoing
investigation I don't think it would be
determinative of any sort of wrongdoings
or but it'll just be more of a
investigative step not the conclusion
but such a very different approach or so
right you know when you put the
juxtaposition in place here in terms of
how you know Bush administration with
you at the helm different than what we
saw today but nevertheless they were
under attack Greg for quite some time
saying that everything was untoward with
respect to the election with Russian
collusion and now you see the layers
peeling back and in fact with a gag
order being lifted to say okay here you
want some transparency there you go I
love how the media is looking at this
it's like they're trying to tell us that
this is nothing after telling us that a
minor meeting was something but somehow
this is nothing it's as if they're
showing us an apple and telling us it's
a banana a little CNN humor there I do
feel bad for Hillary after all it is her
birthday today and I think we should all
go to del Frisco's and get her some
yellow cake exactly he thought she was
going to be celebrating her birthday in
the White House but it seems like it
might be closer to the big house though
we'll be right back he worked on that
all afternoon okay yellow cake was my
favorite so Justice where do you go from
here if you're you know president Trump
and his advisers what do you do in terms
because you want to have to maintain the
propriety and the sanctity of an
investigation while at the same time
giving a bit of a statement to say
listen this is what's going on the embed
suggestion is going forward letting the
American people know and the press that
should be in transparent that you're not
trying to cover up anything there is no
collusion to cover up anything I think
the president's done the right thing so
far he personally asked for this gag
order to be lifted it's odd because his
own FBI and Justice Department have been
stonewalling on a few previous Clinton
scandals so I don't know how this is all
going to play out because I think there
are people within the administration FBI
and the DOJ covering their own tracks
which is very suspicious I want to take
issue with something congressman Schiff
said congressman shift the Democrat
blaming Fox News for this this was the
hill
yeah paper that broke this story not Fox
News I want to clear that up I'm very
interested in what the whistleblowing
everybody else does why not but you know
I want to know why he was gagged I mean
President Obama has a history of gagging
whistleblowers from Benghazi to fast and
furious to Bergdahl I want to hear why
he was gagged I want to hear how the
Russians were trying to curry favor with
the Clintons I'd like to know when this
foreign committee on investment if they
were made aware of this if they weren't
made aware of this why not
or if members of the committee who voted
to approve the sale had any idea there
was bribery going on with the Russians
so all those things I think are going to
lead to very interesting explanations I
want to do a little fact check on Juan
I'm gonna play the Ombudsman for the
show because yesterday he was saying
that all this money flowed into the
Clinton Foundation way way before any of
this happened not true on records show
nine investors in uranium one gave a
hundred and forty five million dollars
to the Clinton Foundation prior to
during and after the vote on the sale
want to make that clear all cells
respond in a minute okay in 2010 as well
as on Bill Clinton went over to Moscow
and was paid a half a million dollars to
give a speech and while he was over
there he met with Putin What did he say
to Putin
why was he also trying to meet with
uranium official all of those things I
want to know I think the bottom line is
this is about selling out America you
know why can we give 20% of
uranium to the Russians but Americans
can't have a tax cut it's just not fair
that's equivalent well first of all as I
tried to explain to you yesterday the
United States really did have an effort
to try to infiltrate Russia's nuclear
activity to try to gain some control and
influence in it but the second thing to
say is of the nine major contributions
to the Clinton Foundation that came from
the effort that the Russians were making
to bribe control influence Americans
most of it I think a hundred and
thirty-five came from one donor and that
donors contributions came years years
before Bill Clinton or Hillary Clinton
were involved and certainly before
Hillary Clinton was Secretary of State
you know why that came in then was the
spring was supposed to be President is
gonna be President maybe that's why that
were given the money that she's a
permanent secretary of state where she
was also a first lady but it's not the
case mister Ombudsman that you're right
if but you hurt yourself I like I'll
leave it there and let the blood flow
okay to the house of horrors because you
mentioned all the houses except the
outhouse but the house of horrors is
where I think Republicans think they
have Hillary Clinton at the moment that
she is being bombarded personally I
didn't know Hillary Clinton was this
important I thought she lost the
election need a horse to whip in it on
the Democratic side I guess Obama's not
see referring to her as a horse okay the
Democrats denials are piling up
President Trump calling out his former
opponent for reportedly knowing nothing
about her campaigns funding of research
to harm mr. Trump's candidacy Hillary
Clinton totally denied this she didn't
know anything she knew nothing all of a
sudden I found out what I was amazed at
it's almost six meeting
in dollars that they paid and it's
totally discredited it's a total phony I
call it fake news it's disgraceful did
you know that yeah we did you know who
else doesn't buy that the secretary only
learned about the dossier after it was
published her former campaign spokesman
listen you have said previously in the
last 24 hours
you don't believe Hillary Clinton knew
about this either is that right oh I
don't know I well I mean she may have
known but the degree of exactly what she
knew is beyond my knowledge that was
awkward someone sounds like they don't
want to test the lie later okay so look
I think he doesn't know and here's the
thing she said she didn't know and that
if she had known she wished they had
used some of this information about
potential relationships between the
Trump campaign and the Russians in terms
of getting the message out advertising
making it plain what was going on and by
the way let me just tell you a huge
Democratic lament Obama Obama knew
something was going on never said a word
and people are like oh so you assume
Hillary's gonna win who's to blame here
but I just wanted to pick up on
something that comes out of this which
is to me we have two separate worlds you
know it's like Venus and Mars men and
women Republicans and Democrats and it's
like two different stories so much so
that now in the Senate Judiciary
Committee
they've even stopped working together
and and Dianne Feinstein the Democrat
from California says I'm going to do my
investigation and Charles Grassley the
Republican chair of the committee from
Iowa says I'm gonna do my investigation
and we'll get together when we come back
to trump and Russia but for now we're
going on each separate way same thing in
the house all these committees Devin
Nunez I thought he was gone now he's
back again working as what looks like a
stand-in for President Trump and as
Jesse just said who ever heard of the
president directing the Department of
Justice and the FBI with regard to
whether somebody has a confidentiality
agreement do you think that President
Trump hasn't has a stake in this fight
they're also two or two though one of
the world is the mainstream media and
the rest of the world is America in the
sense of the media is not excited over
this story
it's Pulitzer prizing turf but
unfortunately it's not
about Trump whereas America would
probably be interested in this but the
media is like saying no no no it if it
doesn't involve DT forget it you know
what the New York Times just went off I
mean went off Maggie Haberman and others
she's special but I'd say she knows
she's special okay I don't know why he's
different someone yeah yes because they
said that Elias who apparently is the
one who paid the check to Fusion GPS
lied to them yeah so I don't see how you
would say oh with the media if this
wasn't about you know the media is
hiding something for Hillary that's not
actually it is because her friend
Stephanopoulos on ABC this morning only
gave this story Iranian 30 seconds you
know how much time he devoted to the
Trump jr. Trump Tower meeting minutes
big discrepancy meeting that was driven
by the questionable dossier that they
paid for the whole salacious thing was
mostly true well I actually looked at
the dossier for some of the findings
huan'er the club by the way do not bring
up anything about women and beds that
was obviously false all right this is
what it says the Kremlin supplied Trump
with a regular flow of intelligence
about Democrats was that true Trump was
offered various sweetener business deals
by the Kremlin but turn them down don't
think that's true also Trump's personal
lawyer Michael Cohen was the point man
for meetings with Kremlin officials in
the Czech Republic never been to the
Czech Republic and Trump's team used
moles within the DNC to hack the DNC
along with the Russians never previous
if those all are erroneous so I don't
see how you can sit here and say the
Trump does it's mostly true and all that
I just read you isn't all right I'm buds
Minh rest your case no well I do think
that the White House is smart to talk
about this because to your point that if
the White House had not mentioned it if
President Trump had not talked about it
in the interview with Lou Dobbs on Fox
Business then it wouldn't be even gotten
30 seconds of coverage on Good Morning
America or other places but remember
most people are getting their news now
from social media the majority the
majority
people get the majority of their news
from social media so it does get a
little polarized on both sides so
whenever this investigation is finished
I have a feeling that most people have
already made up their minds so true I
mean that's the thing they've already
got it and who's winning and all this is
Putin because the whole point of this
was undermining an American institution
and we are undermining ourselves over
this story yep I would cause that's a
big picture there yeah sorry we wrap
that up